while Fire and Blood states that  rhaenyra suffers in childbirth for Days  the show depicts her labor as lasting  one night her daughter who she names for  senya is stillborn in both the book and  the series but Fire and Blood describes  a child not only as deformed but part  Dragon it's up to the reader's  interpretation of This Means raynera's  child was literally a dragon human  hybrid or if it's a euphemism for the  result of generations of incest as we've  seen in just one season of House of the  Dragon Targaryen pregnancies don't have  a great track record the fact that  rhaenyra managed to birth five healthy  children is practically a miracle The  House of the Dragon season 1 finale  doesn't shrink away from her graphic sex  labor and lifeless for senya is shown  with a poorly formed skull and missing  limbs perhaps as a nod to her  dragon-like qualities in the book The  senya's Birth is integer with flashes of  Cyrax roaring as a rider wails in pain  and grief